foreign
this article right here is interesting
it says almost half of gen Z's have side
jobs as money fears take over according
to Deloitte and here's the stat 46
percent of gen's ears currently have
either a full-time or part-time job in
addition to their main one a new
Deloitte survey shows and the figure is
slightly lower for Millennials at 37
percent it goes on to say side jobs are
on the rise as folks struggle to make
ends meet some of the most popular
second jobs are selling products and
services online working gig economy jobs
like food delivery or ride hailing
artistic Outlets or creating social
media content as an influencer look at
that
it says while money is the top reason
for having a side job respondents also
see it as a way to monetize their
Hobbies unplug from their primary job
expand their networks and in some cases
develop skills for a new career path and
of course the survey shows that cost of
living is the biggest concern and it's
especially pertinent as over half of
each generation say they live paycheck
to paycheck five percent more than a
year ago
so here's what this tells me obviously
there's a sad part to this of
inflation's crazy or in debt like crazy
people are trying to make ends meet so
they're turning to these jobs for those
reasons but there's a byproduct of this
that I love that they mentioned
which is it monetizes their Hobbies it
helps them unplug from their primary job
it expands their networks and helps them
to develop skills for a new career path
and I live this out in my 20s as I sat
there with forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt and credit card debt
going oh my gosh I did everything the
system told me to do everything Society
told me to do I worked hard in school
got good grades so I could get into the
College of my dreams only to find out I
couldn't afford the College of my dreams
and then you take out student loans to
pay for it because you had to because
there's no other way and this is how you
get by and make it
and so what do you do as a 22 year old
23 year old sitting there with a pile of
debt and mommy and daddy aren't around
to help you anymore well I turned to
side jobs and of course I got my first
big boy job here at Ramsey Solutions 10
years ago which was awesome
but I went through Financial Peace
University for the first time back in
2013 and it got me fired up to pay off
this forty thousand dollars and I wanted
to do it fast and so on top of my salary
I went what else could I be doing
and so I use my skills my marketing
know-how and I was a second shooter for
videography for weddings I was building
websites using Squarespace for small
businesses and entrepreneurs and authors
and speakers charging you know 1500
bucks a website I was driving for Uber
and Lyft on the weekends instead of
going out with my friends to make an
extra 100 bucks 200 bucks 300 bucks
I also was a Nielsen family if you know
what that is which means Nielsen who is
does all the ratings for you know TV
media radio like this show and I carry
it around a little beeper-sized device
that would listen to all the media that
I listened to and I would get paid based
on how long I had that turned on and I
cannot tell you how uncool I looked in
my khaki pants carrying around a little
beeper but it made me an extra 20 bucks
a month and it was almost no work on my
end
on top of that I was in marketing at the
time so I went I could do some marketing
Consulting and so I started doing that
for those small businesses for
entrepreneurs and helped them launch
podcasts and launch Books uh and as I
stepped into an MC and host role I went
okay I have talents on stage to be a
host in MC I can go do this for other
events and so I did that to help us save
for a down payment when it came time for
us to get a house I also was a musician
and so I would license my music online
to make some extra money that way and
you know sometimes it'd be 50 bucks for
a wedding video or a Church's video and
sometimes it would be Ford saying hey we
want to use your music on our YouTube
channel and I'd get a 1500 check for one
song that I had already recorded and so
there's a lot of creative ways to make
money out there depending on your
talents I have zero talents when it
comes to handyman work when it comes to
cooking and baking but something all out
there
have amazing talent and people will pay
for those adorable smash cakes for the
one-year-old's birthday party and for
that wedding cake when they're on a
budget and can't go to the fancy Bakery
and people will pay to have light bulbs
changed out because they're too lazy
they can't do it physically because
they're older have disabilities whatever
the reason is you would be shocked at
what people are willing to pay for and
we know rich people are scared of leaves
they hire people just to blow the scary
leaves away
I pay people to watch my dog to mow my
lawn to do the electrical work that I
have no clue what I'm doing and I don't
want to sit there on a Saturday watching
YouTube videos from some guy named Larry
who's going on for 30 minutes about how
it was back in his day while trying to
teach me how to change the socket out
and so get creative with this think
about three things your time
your talent and your target
time is simple how much time do you have
to devote to these side hustles
some people it's two hours some people
it's 20 hours
some of y'all that are single out there
and you're sitting at home figuring out
who the next bachelor's gonna be and
who's going to get kicked off the island
yo there is so much work to be done out
there that you can make 20 25 30 bucks
and beyond your time and your talent
which is what what are you good at and
let me tell you if you have a car you
are hopefully good at driving and you
can deliver packages for Amazon Flex you
can deliver groceries with shipped or
instacart
and so beyond any having any talents or
time we all have a Target what are you
doing this for because if you're just
doing it because you're bored that's
fine but if you're doing it because you
want to get out of debt you're going to
stick to it you're going to work harder
at it you're going to work harder for
those tips and you're going to make some
good money and I'll throw a list at you
right now rattle some off because a lot
of you hear Dave say go deliver pizzas
and you're like okay I want to deliver
pizzas first of all pizza delivery can
make some great money
and here's a list number one working
overtime a lot of you have jobs you can
work overtime
people can flip Furniture you can get
that couch Facebook Marketplace that's a
little Dusty a little crusty you get
that couch for 50 bucks you clean it up
you take better photos of it and you can
re-list it
for 200 bucks like that
you can flip things that you buy at
Goodwill
you can sell old clothes on Poshmark and
online you can sell stuff on Facebook
Marketplace you can dog sit
through apps like Rover you can dog walk
through an app called wag Child Care is
a huge one there is a huge shortage of
babysitters right now and babysitting
has gotten crazy expensive
I'm to I'm here parents saying oh yeah
our babysitter charges 30 bucks now an
hour 35 bucks 40 bucks an hour for two
and I'm going oh my goodness why are we
not all just babysitting constantly
house cleaning this is a huge one you
can make a hundred two hundred dollars
for sitting there for a few hours and
scrubbing a toilet because someone else
didn't want to
you can donate plasma
Josiah from our borrowed future
documentary this was a way he made
hundreds of dollars a month for his
family that helped him get out of debt
of course you can drive for Lyft and
Uber deliver food with ubereats and
doordash grocery delivery through
instacart and shipped you can teach ESL
or teach through VIP kid or go go kid
tutoring cutting grass mowing the lawn
doing the yard work pulling the weeds
power washing snow plowing
valet parking bartending on the side
focus groups research studies retail
jobs
that are now paying 15 or 20 bucks an
hour
you can be a transcriptionist on sites
like rev.com where you just type out
things you're hearing for money that's a
cool way to make some extra dough
mystery shoppers if you've got a camera
and some know-how you could do
photography videography graphic design
work if you've got some photoshop skills
you can help people move help them pack
help organize you can be a virtual
assistant you can be a financial coach
we have a great program that trains
Financial coaches and some of these
Financial coaches out there they're
making amazing money helping people
follow the Ramsay plan
and you can make 150 bucks a session
doing that while making an impact
so don't tell me you can truthfully
there are so many ways in America today
to make money so you can tell me you
won't you can make all the excuses in
the world but don't tell me that you
can't make more money in America today
to keep up with inflation to get out of
debt to save the down payment to build
wealth
and that's not forever it's a season so
ask yourself what am I willing to do
right now that's going to set me up for
the long term what am I willing to do
and none of the people that do this
stuff look back with the regret
their kids watch them work hard and
those kids end up working hard because
they saw mom and dad do that so whatever
that goal is look at your time and your
talent and your Target and go after it
and get creative and see what happens